daters listen up anyone here dating or
looking or interested yes yes yes well
science says it takes just three seconds
to decide if you're attracted to someone
okay so what this is true in three
seconds you know and this is what they
base it on best life as experts and the
five things top five things people
notice on a date are teeth clothes body
language your laugh and as the date goes
on your ratio of speaking and listening
okay I think they missed one right Woody
I know what you're gonna I I know the
most important thing to you that's not
on that list uh being kind to people
that one okay and then the other one yes
of course
humor I mean if they well they said the
sound of their laughs so I figured
laughs at jokes humor is being had well
if they're laughing that means you're
funny it's like how do I sound are you
making me laugh that's the most
important thing the fact that the word
laugh was in there made me think that
humor was involved in the conversation
okay fair enough